è la gt ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo su un gioco
particolare che ho trovato sull'app
store che si chiama mega quiz gaming
praticamente un quiz di gaming avreste
mai detto
c'è molta gente che mi chiede battuta di
videogiochi sei bravo non ne sai una
mazza in realtà credo di non saperne una
mazza ci sono un sacco di cose da fare
di sfide da sbloccare la prima
riconoscere i personaggi principali che
la più semplice in poche parole
personaggi principali vai che gioco fa
appartenente praticamente una sorta di
cui di quiz dove devo trovare il nome
della dello zio
ok harms ci ho fatto anche un video su
giusto let's go bay bay sempre detto io
che devo portare make up su youtube in
un video giochi cioè io di di indizi
posso metterne quanti quanti ne voglio
inazuma eleven va bene non avrei mai
azzeccato la cavo lo dico cioè non ci ho
mai giocato quindi pur non hai più
indizi a tua madre morta
vabbè senza facciamo così andiamo
direttamente su quelli che so super meat
boy e fin qui ci siamo
next è che ce ne sono alcuni che
veramente sono un casino altri che sono
delle cagate incredibile jeep grand
theft auto
io immagino tutta la gente nei commenti
non mi mandate messaggi che sono
occupato sono mi sto concentrando
immagino tutta la gente nei commenti che
diceva vi non sai una sega di niente ci
hanno pure ragione vestiti male
simulator noe inside giacca 4 bello
inside bellissimo ma facciamo un sequel
questo non lo so però ci ha tre lettere
potrei anche a tentare di indovinarlo
the fun fest fest so io raga ve lo giuro
non ne ho idea passo avanti però
demandano tutti quelli che lo conoscono
si stanno tagliando le vene fortissimo
però ve lo giuro la canna
con noi deve anche con l'indizio non
solo azzeccare due lettere non riesco a
un ex the binding of isaac
la cosa che mi fa ridere che questi
coach ciani nomi incredibili li conosco
tutti sia quelli tre lettere non li
conosco ha come solo fantastico sono
proprio esperto questo qualcosa mi dice
però non ne sono sicuro
eccolo qua adesso sì che ho trovato il
nome giusto perché fra tutti quanti
proprio questo che la gente adesso che
lo vede ritorna la nostalgia malizia o i
miei capelli la mattina simulator dragon
ball
però non so se chi non so i giochi
dragon ball fighter ha tra l'altro è
aggiornatissimo ad ora sto gioco figo
palo palo all it di planet ma doc
efficacia il primo è perché poi gli
altri non come stai bene grazie è
compreso nel prezzo chiedermi come sto
sono single e non trovo la tipa mi vesto
male non so come tagliarmi la barba ha
della stoffa smi che hanno nuovo capito
è quella stoffa se io ragazzi l'ho
giocato per i cazzi miei non l'ho
portato sul canale perché sono stupido
però ci sono quei giochi che ogni tanto
gioco da solo senza registrarli perché
mi piace la trama che oggi hanno adesso
qualsiasi gioco esistente sul serio da
quanti secoli e che non faccio gli under
simulator veramente 12 anni dio mio a
questo difficile professor layton un
vero gentiluomo risolvere ogni nigma che
sta roba e pokémon vero che roma è rega
pokémon pokémon qualcosa se non lo so io
non regalo un gioco piace kg pagando una
vita quindi non so o mio dio poiché un
calzino pokémon socks raga non lo so
pokemon plus poiché mons
cos'è sta roba ma cos'è ma sono un
deficiente ma vaffan
ma va a cagare come ho fatto a non
pensarci su per chi non era minuti
mentre ve lo giuro non era venuto in
mente i pokemon sole pensavo fosse uno
dei pokemon quelli strani tipo bondage
pokemon mystery dungeon che non sono
proprio con i pokémon classico comunque
io farei un appello per pokémon bus
mi sa proprio di bel capitolo questo non
me lo chiedere neanche risentivo 4
grande resident ma doge che in dax ma
che mi stanno facendo tornare tutta
l'infanzia in giro questi giochi che
sono appena passati sono stati la mia
infanzia c'è proprio bellissimi
rigiocherei ancora adesso tra l'altro
ben 19 su 30 raga non è male non è male
se penso che non sono una mazza però
come vabbè ho fatto un miliardo di rob e
mi sono sbloccato almeno i nemici comuni
quindi nemici comuni a nome al sempre
nome del gioco della stoffa ha quindi
devo sempre indovinare il gioco in base
al nemico che è dead space
io proverei a fare questo quiz e darlo a
mia mamma voglio dire quanti ne azzecca
quanto brutto freddi fai da tè freddi e
thank you so much super 8 e va come poi
addirittura super ma quanti giochi
strani hanno messo dentro addirittura
super hot non l'avrei mai detto sì
comunque quello che cattivo di super hot
che sarebbe anche il protagonista è però
vabbè pietro
a no questa è 40 cultura videoludica in
un solo uomo
penso di essere l'unica persona non da
indovinare quelli più strani ma poi li
più strane con i più semplici non ho
idea di quali siano veramente un idiota
senza tempo vabbè dovrei aver sbloccato
almeno la terza icone o almeno quello
vinto qua qua secondo me le azzecca
tutte giuro station non troppo difficile
mi raccomando dopo ho sbagliato a
scrivere
ok league of tua sorella
basta mandano i messaggi mi chiama
possibile che oggi o yemen come dio
dhabi la bri wow sono un fire sono un
fire sono fire tutti tutti tutti sono un
firewall tutti di stam st m porca vacca
sono troppo un fire vai così quanto un
fire
guardalo temi che un fenomeno tutto da
una società una per ora origin mito
incredibile otto di fila rega bordo work
possono fare non sento fenomeno niguarda
geometria incredibile let's go baby boks
ma porca vacca non aspetta
pensavate i fossi fermato è in rotta mi
sono sorpreso anch'io di me stesso prova
dragon age fenomeno fenomeno incredibile
tutto clash of cats c'è un momento in
cui ho azzeccato tutto l'anno sbato pi
niente gran turismo da lì che fenomeno
guarda la guardano i play ci credo sta
seccando tutti assurdo destino cioè vuoi
mettere
guarda logica la prima le per queste
aree la prima pagina da roche click in
poi tutti tutti incredibile ragazzi mi
mancano quattro stelle per sbloccare i
personaggi principali di nuovo questore
cia tre lettere non possono rendere
questo die for fair fi e fb r vabbè
chiediamo un altro indizio va z z ma
date che roba è anche supervalutato non
ha mica dopo che un gameplay visto gioco
perché mica mister mi ha mandato in
palla completamente il cervello non ho
mai visto facciamo come ultima roba
diamo un'occhiata al volo agli ultimi
personaggi per vedere di che si tratta e
poi basta giusto per vedere se li sono
meno allora metroid e poi abbiamo gente
veramente brutta comunque si alcuni di
questi conosco altri meglio non
conoscerli però vabbè tipo queste zelda
brit of the wild e lo devi indovinare da
un forziere e due pezzi di carne ma
siete maledettamente prendiamo teniamo
questo video family friendly che meglio
dei ragazzi basta per me ho dato prova
di saper e pochissimo però vabbè quando
si sapeva già
spero che vi sia piaciuto concludo
questo quiz gaming che ci tenevo a fare
almeno una volta giusto per darvi
dimostrazione che faccio sempre un po
schifo nei quiz pro capite vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosi si finisce per
quanto mi piace anche vari social
comitato tale descrizione socialisti
scadere ci vediamo
[Musica]